هجمه متزامنه بطائرات قصيره تطالب مواقع
عسكريه في تهران واصفهان والكراج وهمدان
[تصفيق]
الحرس الثوري يعترف بهاجمات
المسيراتها بزياره رئيس المخابرات
الامريكيه لاسرائيل
وترامب يبدا حملته الانتخابيه بمهاجمه بيض
ويدعو انصاره للعمل على ازاحته من البيت
الابيض
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى فتره اخباريه جديده
من العربيه نبداها بهذه النشره اقر الحرس
الثوري الايرانيه بهجوم بطائرات المسيره
على موقع العسكريه في اصفهان وزاره الدفاع
الايرانيه اعترفت بالهجوم وقالت ان دفاعات
الجويه تتصدت له وكان ناشطون ايرانيون
اكدوا سماع عدوي انفجارات عده استهدفت
مصنعا لذخيرها في اصفهان فيما تنقلت مواقع
ايرانيه انفجارات اخرى استهدفت مواقع فيها
مدادا والكراج وراجست وقاعده نوجا
وبالتوازي تحدثت مصادر اعلاميه اسرائيليه
عن عمليه الدخل الايراني وربطت بين طوقتها
وزياره رئيس الاستخبارات الامريكيه
المركزيه السياسيه الى تل ابيب
[موسيقى]
اليوم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ليست جديده من نوعها فقط سبقتها عده
انفجارات وحرائق في جميع انحاء المنشات
العسكريه والصناعيه الايرانيه في عام 20
21 اتهمت ايران اسرائيل بتخريب مفاعلنا
طنز نوير رئيسي وللمفارقه تزمن ذلك ايضا
استهداف مع زياره وزير الدفاع الامريكي ان
ذاك اسرائيل ماذا فعل كثير من وسائل
الاعلام الايرانيه المعارضه والاسرائيليه
لربط توقيت هذه التفجيرات في اصفهان
وغيرها من المدن الايرانيه بزياره رئيس
الاستخبارات الامريكيه المركزيه سي اي اي
الى تل ابيب وقعت انفجارته في مواقع
ايرانيه حساسه في بعض الاحيان طالت شخصيه
فاعله في النظام الايراني كالعالم النووي
محسن فخري زاده وفي يوليو تموز الماضي
قالت ايران انها اعتقلت مجموعه مخربه تعمل
لصالح اسرائيل كانت تخططه لتفجيله ركز
صناعيه دفاعيه حساس في اصفهان وتهدد
اسرائيل منذ وقت طويل بالقيام بعمل عسكري
ضد ايران اذا فشلت المحدثات غير المباشره
بين واشنطن وطهران في انقاذ الاتفاق
النووي المبرم عام 2015
هو في ايران ايضا درس شباكم مسلح بين
الاكراد والقوات الامنيه في مدينه جوان
وود بمحافظه كرم منشاه الكرديه غرب البلاد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اتهمت الولايات المتحده ثلاثه اشخاص تم
توجيههم من قبل النظام الايراني بمحاوله
اغتيال الصحفيه الايرانيه الامريكيه مسيح
علي نجاه في مدينه نيويورك الاشخاص الثلاث
رقبه صحفيه بمنزلها في نيويورك في يوليو
20 22 ولكنها فرط عند ملاحظتها نشاطا
مشكورا حسب وزاره العدل الامريكي دخول
جولف هذه هي الصحفيه والناشطه الايرانيه
الامريكيه مسيحه للنجاد تستنجد من اضطهاد
النظام الايراني
وزاره العدل الامريكيه تكشف اسمائها وصور
المتهمين المعتقلين المعنيين بخطفها العمل
الماضي وهم رافات اميروز وبولاد عماروف
وخالد مهديه العدل الامريكيه تقول ان
الاشخاص الثلاثه ثم توجيههم من قبل النظام
الايراني لخطفي على نجاه وان الفريق
استهدف في السابق ضحايا اخرين في كندا
وبريطانيا بدا الافراد الثلاثه بمراقبه
على نجاد في يوليو الماضي بشكل متكرر
بالصور والفيديو وخطط اميروف وعماروف
لتزويد مهديين بمبلغ ثلاثين الف دولار
لشراء بندقيه وذخائر وفي ال 28 من يوليو
في العام الماضي لاحظت على نجاد نشاطا
مشكورا خارج منزلها الواقعي بمنهات في
نيويورك وغادرت وبعد ان ابتعد مهديه عن
منزل الضحيه تم ايقافه لمخالفه مروريه
وتقل حين تم العثور على سلاحه و100 دولار
وقنا عند تزلج اسود اماميروف فعتقل خارج
الولايات المتحده وقتيده الى مكان احتجاج
امريكي بينما القي القبض على عمره في
الشيك في وقت سابقا من يناير وتسع
الولايات المتحده لتسللمه المؤامره
المحبطه من قبل تخطيط اجهزه المخابرات
الايرانيه كانت عباره عن خطف الفريق لمسيح
علي النجاد ونقلها الى ايران عبر زورق
سريع لفنزويلا منذ يونيو الماضي على الاقل
وفق الوزاره كان فريق المخابرات الايراني
يقدم وثائقي مزوره ولكذبه بشان هدفه كما
استخدم الفريق محققين خاصين لمراقبه
الضحيه في عده حالات في عام 2020 و 2021
وفي تغريده لها اعلنت مسيحيه لنجاد ان
مكتبه تحقيقات الفيدراليه ابلغها باعتقالي
من وظيفتهم ايران لقتلها وعلقت بان الحرس
الثوري الايراني يقوم بهذه العمليات منذ
اربعه عقود رشا خياط العربيه
ضربه زلزال بقوه 5.9 درجه على مقياس
ريختار من طاقه بالقرب من مدينه خوي في
محافظه اذربيجان الغربيه وحسب بعض وسائل
الاعلام المحليه فقد قتل شخصا على الاقل
في الزلزال الذي شعر به سكان في معظم مدن
شمال غرب ايران كما اعلن المتحدث باسم
خدمات الطوارئ في مدينه خوي عاصمه اقليم
اذربيجان ان حجم الدمار الذي لحق بالمنازل
والابنيه بالمدينه كان كبيرا نسبيا
انهت الحكومه الاسرائيليه الامنيه اجتماعا
اتخذت خلاله سلسله قرارات من بينها تسريع
منح تراخيص حمل سلاح لالاف المستوطنين
والاسرائيليين بالاضافه الى فرض عقوبات
على عائلات منافذ العمليات مثل اغلاق او
هدم المنازل
اسرائيل على مواجهه العمليات الفرديه غير
المنظمه ولا عنواننا للرد عليها حاول
نتنياهو عندما تلا اهم قرارات الحكومه
الامنيه المصغره ان يطفي بعدا دراما تكيا
على القرارات لاحتواء غضب الشارع اليمني
ربما
ودقيقه من يحاول المسافه بين سنستهدفه
ونستهدف كل من يساعده لقد اجرينا اعتقالات
في صفوف دعميه الارهاب والمحرضين وننشر
ونعزز القوه على الجبهات المختلفه
تسهيل ترخيص حمل السلاح للاسرائيليين وسد
او هدموا منازل عائلات منفذين عمليات
ومحاوله تشريع قانون يتيح ابعاد عائلات
المنفذين من القدس والداخل الى جانب تعزيز
الاجراءات الامنيه كانت ابرز ما توافقت
عليه الحكومه الامنيه
بشكل كبير لذلك يتوقع ان يكون خطوات
تصعيديه عقوبات جماعيه وهذا سيغذي يعني
حاله احتمال موجوده والعمليات ربما نحن
امام موجه قد تمتد واذا امتدت ربما يعني
تقود الى وضع همم تفلت فيه الامور وتفقد
فيه السيطره بشكل كامل في اسرائيل ليقرون
بان العمليات الفرديه كالتي جرت في
مستوطنه في القدس الشرقيه المحتله وقتل
فيها سبعه مستوطنين او تلك التي نفذها فتن
في سلوان ضد مستوطنين الى جانب عمليات
اطلاق النار في الضفه
استمر في اطار التصعيد القائم والمتفاقم
وفيما حاولت الحكومه استغلالها للتركيز
على الملف الامني وحرف الانظار عن الازمه
الداخليه بسبب الحرب على النظام القضائي
اصر عشرات الالاف من الاسرائيليين على
التظاهر في تل ابيب حيث اجبر الحكومه على
تغيير موقع الاجتماع وفي مدن اخرى ايضا
زياد حلب العربيه القدس الغربيه
كوريا الشماليه تنتقد قرار الولايات
المتحده تزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات
اهلا بكم من جديد لقيا ثلاثه اشخاص مزرعهم
واصيب 14 اخرون على الاقل في غره الروسيه
اعلى منطقه في دمشق شرق اوكرانيا حسب ما
اعلن رئيس الاوكرانيه
بشكل يومي مشيرا الى ان الجيش الاوكراني
بامكانه ايقاف الهجمات الروسيه اذا تم
تزويده بالصواريخ المناسبه
ورغم صدى الواسع الذي صاحب اعلان الدول
الغربيه تزويد اوكرانيا بالدبابات الثقيله
فان هذه الاسلحه المتقدمه لن تكون الرصاصه
الفضيه التي تسمح لكيا بالانتصار في الحرب
وفقا لتقرير لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز
الامريكيه وبدا من ذلك ستحاول القوات
العسكريه الامريكيه اعاده تشكيل جيش وفقا
لتصورها الخاص لملح اوكرانيا افضل فرصه
الاختراق الدفاعات الروسيه المحصنه حسب
الصحيفه
ان الولايات المتحده وبقيه الحلفاء لم
يضروا الى توفير الدبابات والمدرعات
والذخائر المتطوره فقط بل الى توسيع
برنامج التدريب المخصص للجيش الاوكرانيه
ايضا الدعم انت الدالي يشمل مدافع
وانظمه المدفعيه الصاروخيه هايمررز ثم
الدفاعات الجويه
ومؤخرا المركبات القتاليه المدرعه بما في
ذلك اسرائيل
استخدما من قبل الجيش الامريكي قبل
الاعلان عن الدبابات الثقيله وعلى الرغم
من ان الدبابات كانت محور الاهتمام الى ان
المحللين العسكريين يقولون ان جزءا مهما
من التبرعات الغربيه الاخيره قد يكون
مركبات ردلي القتاليه التي سترسلها
الولايات المتحده ومن المحتمل ان يتم دمج
هذه المعدات مع دبابات تو الالمانيه
للمساعده في انشاء وحدات المدرعه اوكرانيه
جديده
انتقدت كوريا الشماليه الولايات المتحده
بسبب قراريها ارسال دبابات ابرامز
القتاليه الى اوكرانيا واصفه هذا القرار
بانه عمل اجرامي ضد الانسانيه يستهدف
ادامه حاله دوليه غير مستقره وقالت وزاره
الخارجيه الكوريه في بيان ان مزاعم واشنطن
بان بيونغ يونغ قدمت اسلحه هي محاوله لا
اسس لها بهدف تبرير تدخلها في الشان
الاوكراني وتقديم المساعدات عسكريه لها
[موسيقى]
تمسكو بذراعي والدها بانتظار ان تمسك
بزمام الامور في البلاد الطفله المحبوبه
لزعيم كوريا الشماليه
وفق صحيفه التايمز البريطانيه
و بدا هذا الامر واضحا بعد ان كشف كم
النقابه عن ابنته البالغه من العمر عشره
اعوام مخالفه بذلك تقاليد الحكم المتعارف
عليها ليربط الاخلاص له بالولاء لطفلته
لانه ينوي تعزيز فكره انها هي من ستخلفه
تقول صحيفه البريطانيه
ابعد من ذلك ظهور طفلتي كم يهدف الى نزع
فتيل التنافس الحاد بين الامراتين الاكثر
اهميه في حياته وهما زوجته وشقيقته
الطموحه كم يوم جونغ لانه في حاله رحيل كم
من دون ان يكون لديه خليفه معروفه فان ذلك
سيؤدي الى فراغ في السلطه وبالتالي فان
الصراع سيحتدم بين الارمله والشقيقه
فشقيقه كم قويه جدا وعدوانيه وطموحه
وزوجته كم غير راضيه عنها ولاجل ذلك اخرج
الزعيم الكري ابنته الى العالم لتفادي
الصراع وتدهور البلاد في حال وفاته ولكن
حتى الساعه تعد شقيقه زعيم البالغه من
العمر 35 عاما اقوى امراه في البلاد لانها
الاقرب اليه من مساعديه والمتحدثه باسمه
في ما يتعلق بالعلاقات مع كوريا الجنوبيه
على ضروره تعزيز التعاون بين الحلف وكوريا
الجنوبيه لمواجهه النزعه العسكريه
المتجدده للصين
في مقابله نشرتها الوكاله الرسميه لكوريا
الجنوبيه ان كوريا الشماليه تمثل تهديدا
للامن العالمي واشار السلط مدير الى ان
النيترو سيظل حلف النويا ما دامت الاسلحه
النوويه موجوده
بدا رئيس الامريكيه السابق ترامب بشكل
رسمي حملته الانتخابيه في ولايتي نيو
هامشر
كبيرا بحصول المرشحين الفائزين في
انتخابات الرئاسيه التمهيديه على تزكيه
حزبهم لخوض الانتخابات الرئاسيه العامه
بهذه الاجواء الحماسيه تجمعه انصار الرئيس
الامريكي
احدى ولايات التصويت المبكر في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه التمهيديه
مئات الجمهوريين قدموا من مختلف انحاء
الولايه المهمه في الانتخابات التمهيديه
الى عاصمتها كولومبيا لدعم ترامب وتعزيزي
حظوظه في الترشح رغم ان استطلاعات للراي
تظهروا عدد من الجمهوريين في الولايه
يرغبون في ترشح شخص اخر لخوض الانتخابات
الرئاسي
ايييان حلوين
1980 معظم الذين فازوا بالانتخابات
التمهيديه في ولايه الساوث كارولينا حصلوا
على تزكيه حزبهم لخوض الانتخابات الرئاسيه
لهذا ينظر الى هذه الولايه كبوصله في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه
ترامب الذي كان محاط بابرز مؤيديه في ساوث
كارولينا ومنهم السيناتور عن الولايه
لينزي غرام والحاكم ماستر لم يغير من نمره
خطابه المعتاده
اون تايوان
مثل السفيره الامريكيه السابقه لدى الامم
المتحده
حسين الطاوضه من ولايه ساوث كارولينا
العربيه
[تصفيق]
وقعت المؤسسه الوطنيه للنفط في ليبيا
اتفاقا مع شركه ان الايطاليه للطاقه بقيمه
8 مليارات دولار لتطوير لحقول غاز تقترب
احتياطيتها من سته ريونات قدم مكعبه وطاقه
الانتاجيه تتراوح بين 750 و 800 مليون قدم
مكعبه يوميا لفتره تناهز خمسه 25 عاما
زياره رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه الى طرابلس
التي رافقها فيها وزير الداخليه والخارجيه
ومدير عام شركه لم تكن زياره عاديه
[موسيقى]
اتفاقيات مع حكومه الوحده الوطنيه لمجال
الامن والمكافحه الهجره ولكن الاتفاق
الابرز كان بين مؤسسه النفط وشركه والذي
اثار
الحقول الملك اليوم للغاز حتى يتناقص
ممكن بعد ثلاثه اربع سنوات بتقدي في
التنقل لا بد ان نحافظ
ونزيد كميه الغاز المنتجه بشغطي حتى
احتياجات الشارع اللي بيقول شان الليبي
ولا بالنا نحن بنصدر الضغط
100% المؤسسه الوطنيه
عن طرابلس في اتجاه الشمال الغربي داخل
البحر الابيض المتوسط وباحتياطي سته لتر
مكعب من الغاز
وبعدين التركيبين البحريين
تم استكشافهم في السبعينات
وتم الاعلان التجاري عنهن في 2013 وهذا
الموضوع
سيعود بالنفع على
الاقتصاد الليبي سواء كان في شكل عوائد
تصل الى 18 مليار دولار او كان ايضا
توفير الغاز اللي محطه الكهرباء ولتصدير
ايضا الاتفاقيه التي عززت المكانه الرفيعه
للشركه الايطاليه في السوق الليبي اعادت
من جديد الانقسام السياسي بين الاجسام
المسيطره على المشهد على الانقسام لابد ان
رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه تعرف ابعاده جيدا
لكنها تحولات الكبيره في سوق الطاقه في
العالم تتجاوز بعض العقبات احيانا على
الرغم من طبيعه الاتفاقيه النفطيه الموقعه
بين طرابلس وروما ولكنها تحمل في طياتها
العديد من الرسائل السياسيه خصوصا في ظل
المنافسه الاوروبيه على النفط والغاز في
ليبيا منير الاشهب طرابلس العربيه
تسببت موزه البرد التي تشهدها افغانستان
منذ حوالي 20 يوما بوفاه ما لا يقل عن 260
شخصا حيث خفضت درجات الحراره بشكل حاد وسط
قطاع متكرر في التيار الكهربائي ما ادى
الى تضرر حوالين منزل بالتزامن مع تراجع
المساعدات الانسانيه بسبب حضر حكومه
الطالبان على الافغانيات العمل في
المنظمات الانسانيه
في الرقه السوريه التاسعه نطاق مشاركه
المراه في الحياه العامه بعد خمس سنوات
على تحرير المدينه من داعش الذي جرد
المراه من حقوقها الاساسيه الزميل جمع
عكاشه يرفض القطاعات والمجالات التي بدات
المراه تتولى فيها اعلى المناصب
لا تنتشلوا يوسف من بئركم ولا تطوحوا
بنخله الاسير ابتعدوا عني لاكتب نصي
الاخير على ضوء شمعه ذهب الى طالما اشتكت
من صخب المصابيح بصوت عالي
اليوم اشعارها وتقف لتشرح بفخر قصه لوحتها
الوحيده التي نجت من داعش
كانت هذه اللوحه احدى اللوحات التي حافظت
على نفسها ونجت من ارهاب داعش من
تمزيقها اييه هي المراه
التي ناضلت ضد الارهاب وارادت ان تخرج
بالوانها الزاهيه
الى جانب الفني والشاري والرسم افتتحت
حمزاوي عملها الخاص كما انها ترشد مع
المنظمات المدنيه والاحزاب المحليه
لتفعيل دور المراه تشارك قصتها نسوه
اخريات اقتحممنا مجالات الدفاعي وتعملن
اليوم كشرطيات مرور او عناصر امن الى جانب
العمل السياسي اذ اصبحت المراه تتراس
اليوم اكبر الاحزاب السياسيه في المدينه
نلاحظ تواجد مميز وملحوظ للمراه في كافه
مجالات
وميادين والحياه في الرقه سواء الاداريه
سواء العسكريه سواء الاقتصاديه سواء
سياسيه وحتى في منظمات المجتمع المدني
ورغم الخطوات الكبيره التي خططها المراه
في الرقه الا ان قيود كثيره لا تزالوا
تشكل عقبه اساسيه امام توسيع مشاركتها في
الحياه العامه من الرقه جمع كاش العربيه
الغت الخطوط الجويه البريطانيه فلاي بي
كافه رحلاتها وستطبقاء الركاب عالقين
بانتظار رحلات طيران من بديله رغم تاكيد
الشركه انها لن تعيد جدول رحلاتها وتوعد
هذه الشركه واحده من اكبر الخطوط الجويه
في بريطانيا وتعرضت لانتكاسه الماليه ضخمه
عام 2020 جراء جاء احدنا ادت لي افراس
الشركه الا انها عادت لساني في رحلاتها في
ابريل العام الماضي
الختام مع ابرز العناوين
هجمات المتزنه بطائرات قصيره تطالب مواقع
عسكريه في طهران واصفهان و كرج وهمدا
[تصفيق]
الحرس الثوري يعترف بها جامعه المصيرات
ونشيطون يربطون توقيتها بزياره رئيس
المخابرات الامريكيه لاسرائيل
وترامب يبدا حملته الانتخابيه بمهاجمه
البيضاوي انصاره للعمل على ازاحته من
البيت الابيض الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]